hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast emergence of clinical
proteomics identifying and developing
actionable protein biomarkers for use in
clinical research presented by dr. Todd
Ambro
president of proteomics at nan Tomac and
dr. Mary Ann Vogelsang manager of assay
development at nan tomek's I'm Susie
Valdez of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
your presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
you will be viewing the presentation in
a slide window to enlarge that window
just click on the screen icon located at
the lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or use that
Q&A button and let us know you're having
a problem but this presentation is
educational and offers a continuing
education credits please click on the
bottom button in the left corner and
follow the process for obtaining your
credits I'd now like to introduce our
two presenters first up is dr. Todd
Hembrough Todd is the president of
proteomics
at Van tomek's where he is overseeing
our MD operations and the clinical
proteomics laboratory Todd obtained his
PhD in biochemistry from the University
of Virginia's studying the role of
proteases in tumor growth and invasion
prior to nan tomek's Todd was a leader
of the translational oncology efforts at
contra Med focusing on defining
druggable molecule pathways and
inventing new drugs to target
these pathways toddler became the chief
scientific officer and head of R&D at a
complex Diagnostics an expression
pathology we helped lead the development
and commercial launch of the first
quantitative proteomics assay performed
on formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue joining Todd today is our second
presenter dr. Mary and Vogelsang Mary
Ann leads the assay development team and
drives the implementation and delivery
of an tomek's mass spectrometry and this
based assay development pipeline for
both barnsey and clinical proteomics
laboratories Moran earned her PhD in
biochemistry and molecular biology from
the University of California Los Angeles
prior to nan tomek's Mary Ann
established a CLIA complaintant
laboratory that offered both eliza and
mass spec based clinical assays she has
over a decade of experience in
translational medicine utilizing the
mass spectrometry platform and spent a
significant part of a career as a
scientist developing workflows that
facilitate proteomics biomarkers
discovery and validation processes at
Thermo Fisher Scientific Brin Center I
will now turn the presentation over to
our presenters dr. Todd Hembrough and
dr. Marianne bulaga Singh welcome both
of you thank you very much Suzy it's a
pleasure to have an opportunity to
present today and to really dig into how
clinical proteomics is growing and how
we're defining new biomarkers and
helping to set the stage for the
emergence of these biomarkers into
helping to understand cancer so quick
disclosures Mary and I are both
employees of nantou mix at nan telmex we
really focus on three things the first
is we have a cap CLIA clinical lab where
we perform clinical proteomics and
genomics testing of patient samples we
run whole genome sequencing we perform
rna-seq and we prefer perform targeted
proteomics and the idea here is really
to get as much information as possible
about the patient's tumor so that we can
understand the biology of that tumor
second where genomics is a maturing
based proteomics is really nascent so we
want to perform as many studies as we
can to define the utility of these
proteomics assays and in order to do
that we have efforts in discovery where
we're looking to define and discover new
targets and new pathways we have a focus
on clinical studies where we do analysis
of randomized trials looking in a
prospective retrospective way to test
biomarkers that we know we have to see
what their utility is in those studies
and then we also perform prospective
studies where we're helping to define
populations where we think the
biomarkers are important the final area
that we focus on is to work with our
collaborators and clients and the pharma
States to develop clinical biomarkers to
help in a companion diagnostic setting
so I'd like to turn it over to Mary Ann
who's going to describe the technology
about how we do it and here is Mariette
Thank You Todd one of the core goals
core goals of what we do here at Ann
tommix every day is analyze the proteome
of tumor tissue and it all starts with a
tumor biopsy as you look here in this
slide step one
you know we receive samples and we
prepare them on director slides and then
step two we then laser microdissection a
critical part of this step is the mark
up through the pathologist that only
marks the tumor region and only the
tumor region is dissected and collected
and you see in step four it's a
proprietary liquid tissue prep process
that liquefies the tissue and then we
digest it in preparation for the mass
spectrometer and so whatever pots from
utilizes is a triple quadrupole mass
spectrometer and then through analysis
of that data we're able to deliver
quantitative information at the animal
level for every tissue that runs through
our laboratory and using this platform
we've been able to develop a massive
multiplex proteomic panel of clinically
relevant targets a lot of them are
relevant for chemo therapies
immunotherapies as well as agents and
development
and today's presentation all focused a
little bit later on on the development
of the her2 assay and then Todd will
highlight some of our research findings
with the tub three and tenth biomarkers
so as I said before the core goal of
what we do is analyzing the proteome of
tumor tissues and it all starts with
that precious sample samples are
precious and often limited in size and
scope and so it's critical that we're
able to measure as many targets as we
can within a single run because often
were only given one shot and we get one
enough sample for one injection and so a
lot of what we do is build methods
multiplex methods of all the targets and
measure them simultaneously and we have
the power to measure anywhere between 70
and 100 targets at any one time within
an hour and so one of the critical
components of this process is using
isotopically labeled peptides and from
there we're able to accurately identify
and quantitate our vital markers of
interest and give out a quantitative
readout using that ratios you can see
here on the left side which are the
right side of the panel the relative
ratios between the endogenous and heavy
label peptides now in this next slide
I'd like to just sort of highlight our
development process I won't go over a
detail every single step I sort of want
to just highlight what we do differently
here we do a lot of we do have a strong
molecular oncology knowledge base that
we utilize in-house and we also have a
genomics company as part of a division
within man tomek's
and together with strong and college
knowledge as well as genomic data were
able to distill candidate target lists
something else that we do differently is
utilize for comment protein because a
lot of what we do and develop starts off
with a literature knowledge or in silico
understanding we want to be - under we
want to be able to understand how those
proteins and those targets behave
mass spectrometer so we start off with a
recombinant protein digests that get
characteristics of the how that behaves
on the mass spectrometer and then we
order the heavy label peptides that we
think will be robust throughout the
validation process and then as we screen
in early development stage as well as
final validation stage we utilize the
internal standards and all of our tissue
samples and every run and you see right
here as you can see at this last stage
all of the processes that we go through
monitoring the heavy and light peptides
will go through our validation process
which I'll be explained to you today and
try to characterize that performance so
much of what I'll do today I'm going to
make a couple assumptions of the readers
today that you already have your
chromatography selected but just to
highlight what's important in picking
out the right chromatography you know
you want to make sure that you have
distinct peak shapes and ideal
separation as well as robust and stable
retention times additionally the use of
that stable isotope I can't stress
enough as being valuable for this entire
validation process so we go over a
couple parameters that you need to keep
in mind and assessing the performance of
your targets and that's in the mass
spectrum signature or your peak shape
and so you want to make sure that your
attention time is stable from your
isotopically labeled peptide isn't and
is in alignment with your endogenous
peptides of course but you really need
to make sure that that retention time
from run to run is stable and that
enables the multiplexing and the
scheduling capabilities that you have
within the mass spectrometer and also
you want to you know I mentioned before
we calculate the amount of the protein
based on the light to heavy ratio you
also need to be mindful of the
isotopically rate the isotopic ratios of
the transition ions within each peak now
what we do a little differently is our
we build methods that
can sustain different tissue types and
often you have we see you know you can
see different transition ion ratio
performance based on the tissue type and
so you can sorry about that you need to
make sure that your transition iron
ratios are stable across any matrix and
in tissue type and that's what we're
doing here in order to understand the
complete process of how to validate your
targets I'm going to refer you to a
handful of clsi guidelines GLS is a
clinical and laboratory standards
Institute they've published numerous
guidelines and I'd like to call out C 62
A and C 50 a as guidelines that are
invaluable when you're and you should
refer to when you are validating your
targets so they are specifically mass
spec focused when you do reach or these
guidelines you'll notice that there are
the consensus between them and that
outline eight specific steps and
analyzing aren't analytically validating
your methods they range from assessing
specificity accuracy precision and all
the way down to robustness and I'll go
through a couple of these okay and then
these slides in this next slide I'd like
to go over just a few highlights of
those eight processes I'm not going to
read the definitions out loud for you
I'd like you to come back and read these
but however I'd wanna call it two
specific steps
it's the specificity step and the
precision in order to know that you're
undoubtedly measuring the analyte of
interest you need that internal standard
and it'll just help you immeasurably
when you're looking at different mediums
whether it's German plasma and in our
case different tissue types that cover
different indications as well as
precision the precision step measuring
your samples over a period of time
repeatedly no 21 days 30 days
or years later you want to make sure
that your essay is robust and that you
have the same measurement day in and day
out
the next two steps you know limit of
detection limit of quantitation sort of
define and highlight the sensitivity of
your assay and in our case you know
working off of one microgram of tissue
that couldn't be more important however
because we run a large operation I'm
also going to ask you to be mindful when
you really want to take your discoveries
to the next step and look to look at
ruggedness and robustness you want to
make sure that we make sure at least
that our assays perform across different
instruments as well as across different
tissues and that's where you know when
NASA is robust we do see a difference in
how they perform across different tissue
types and we're always mindful of that
and documented in our validation process
now let's go to the fun step I actually
like this slide this slide here slide 14
describes and highlight how we validated
the her2 assay and again in step a you
know we did start off with a recombinant
protein and assess three of the peptides
and peptide LDS was the most robust and
the best performing peptide and so as
you can see here panel rate it is the
ms2 spectrum of that heavy peptide and
well as in penalty you can I'm calling
out for the transition ions that we're
using to quantitate and the top half is
the light and the bottom half is a heavy
peptide and so this assay performs well
over a wide dynamic range as you can see
in panel B it is gives us a linear
performance from 150 animals to 225
thousand animals and in panel E this is
one of my favorite figures part of the
triggers because it highlights how
robust are and how rugged RSA is across
different instruments if you look at the
y-axis and the x-axis we're comparing
two different instruments and if you're
looking at the difference in color we're
also showing how well our how well our
as they perform under different
she types we have bread but we have
breast cancer as well as gastro
esophageal cancer and when looking at
panel f you can see how important
precision is and often the mass
spectrometer lends itself to the ability
to build robust assays time and time
after time as well as the yeast in our
case a formalin-fixed tissue we're able
to see a strong performance of the assay
across you know one-year part you can
see the x-axis the freshman prepared
tumor tissue samples as well as one from
a year ago on the y-axis we still get a
high degree of agreement and I'd like to
refer you to our paper last year in
gastric cancer for more details you see
so we do perform all the steps for every
assay that comes through a lab but one
of the power powerful components of
being able to build a phase on the mass
spectrometers this idea of multiplexing
so we have to run as many targets as we
can you know seventy to a hundred
targets at one point however every time
you do add another target into your
message you need to be mindful that
you're not compromising the ability and
performance of that se you designed
before it so you want to be mindful of
your peak shape points across the peak
and signal-to-noise every time you add
to your methods and when you're
validating your assay it's always going
to be a balancing act between throughput
and sensitivity and initially we started
out in the sensitivity on one microgram
tissue is essential however because we
know that we need to be able to measure
as many targets as we can across
indications
3-putted throughput is equally valuable
in our case and I challenge you to think
about these components as you're
developing your own assays in your
laboratory and with that I'd like to
hand it over to Todd who will talk about
the clinical utility of these assays in
our research laboratory Thanks
Maryann that was great and you know from
my perspective as a as a molecular
oncologist what what we've always looked
at is that the mass spec is this really
powerful tool and we can get all this
information and as you said the critical
point is validate the assays so that you
can trust the data so that you can run
it again and again year in and year out
and you can always trust the data and I
think that what Maryann has shared is
there's just a snapshot of the really
strong detail-oriented focus on making
sure that it's it's being done perfectly
so then the challenge for us is does it
matter you know within the oncology
space where we work there's many many
ideas that fail to be proved
scientifically and logic and oncology
don't really overlap so what we what we
did is we started at the beginning we
started with an assay that everybody
understood within the oncology space her
- where - as a as a kinase receptor it's
a driver and on breast cancer and it's a
it's a target that there are drugs in
the clinic and everybody knows how to
use the data so we started by comparing
how mass spectrometry compares with the
standard assay which is called
immunity's - chemistry where antibody
staining is performed on a tissue
so in this slide in the middle you can
see these these boxes with IHC we
received 19 to mer samples from md
anderson and we reprocess them to show
that each of those samples was indeed
highly staining for her - by a monistic
chemistry now in the clinic this is a
this is a diagnostic test that's
performed to tell the patient the
physician to treat this patient with her
to therapy
now what we really wanted to know is how
well was that assay performing and we
were surprised to discover that when we
took 19 samples that were all identical
what we saw was a 100 fold range of
protein expression within this
population of seemingly identical
immunohistochemistry and so you can see
the
the assumption that we have is we
believe that the different parts of this
population will actually perform
differently in the clinic and so in
order to test this we we took this and
collaborated with the laboratory in
Spain and we looked at their experience
with fish with immunohistochemistry and
with what we performed which was
targeted for younger and again where the
clinical research folks who focus on
fish and I see they see these things as
the same they see her to fish as
positive to say I HD 3 plus as positive
and again what we see is this vast
dynamic range of expression of her2
protein now again the the punchline here
for us is we believe that the patients
who have lots of protein and have no
protein oughta behave differently when
they're treated with therapies and so we
took this population and then and looked
at how the patients responded to the
drugs now this is a retrospective study
we got clinical research samples from
the Val Gibran Institute of oncology in
Spain and we performed all of this
analysis long after the patients were
treated so this is the this is the
canonical clinical research study where
we're looking at performance and we're
trying to associate how the expression
of protein translates into outcome in
these clinical research samples and as
you can see on this slide I'm sort of
selling the punchline which is we found
quantitative proteomic cut-offs
which were predicted for fish
amplification at 7:40 and are predicted
for benefit on the drug which I'll show
you on the next slide so in this
population of breast cancer patients who
were treated in the adjuvant setting
when we separated the population based
on this cutoff of 2200 animals what we
saw is that those patients had it the
morally different outcome the patients
who had lots of her to responded very
well to her - and in fact none of them
died in this study whereas the patients
who had less or very low levels of her 2
juice on the last slide performed worse
now this corresponds to what we
hypothesized which is patients with lots
of her2 protein should be responding to
the targeted therapy better and patients
with very little or - shouldn't be so we
saw the same phenotypic response in the
metastatic setting so these are the two
key settings for breast cancer adjuvant
setting where there's surgery and then
treatment and metastatic where the
patient shows up with metastatic disease
and again in both cases in the
metastatic setting this cutoff was able
to separate the patients who performed
well in the top curve versus the
patients who whose tumors didn't respond
to the therapy and who sadly perished
more quickly now the exciting thing
about this from the mass spectrometry
perspective is in looking at these
patient samples and again in the
clinical research setting there's no
other way to analyze these patients and
see this data when one uses the other
standard ways to measure her - in these
patients either fish I see gene copy
number they don't see this separation so
what we have with mass spectrometry is a
very powerful tool to look at what's
really going on biological and new
samples and understand how that the
biology differs between patients that
look the same with other technologies
now one of the assumptions that we have
is that biology drives cancer so what we
know is that her - is expressed highly
it's amplified in breast cancer but it's
also highly expressed in gastric cancer
so the hypothesis when we stepped into
this next study is that the behavior of
her - in both diseases should be the
same it's a driver
it's an oncogene and it's targetable so
this is a second clinical research study
where we took patients who had been
treated in the past they had been part
of a clinical trial and what we're doing
is we're analyzing this tissue in order
to understand how her - expression is
relevant to the response that the
patient showed with these therapies so
again in this slide you can see the
distribution of IFC
as we showed you in the last slide in
the three plus which is the the
expression level where these patients
are given being given therapy you can
see that once again there's an extremely
broad dynamic range of expression
including patients who actually have no
protein expression whether
immunohistochemistry may in fact be
spurious and so when we look at this
population what we see is two subsets of
patients patients who express lots of
her to but because their immunities to
chemistry was low
they wouldn't have been recognized as
expressing lots of her2 and then a
population where their immunities to
chemistry says they have a lot of her
too but what we see is low expression by
protein so as we showed in the breast
cancer study o our hypothesis is that
this this patient population number two
is the population that when they are
treated with or to therapy will be less
likely to respond to the therapy so when
we did this study we perform what's
called a prospective retrospective study
we defined the cut-offs we tested the
cut-offs in order to see how this
population performed using our
diagnostic and so you can see that the
conduct here that was tested was
eighteen hundred and twenty five animals
of her2 and this was a randomized
clinical trial that was performed
we got the tissue and then we processed
it and so what I want to highlight here
is on the right hand side is the fact
that this is overall survival and that
we have three different cohorts within
the study there's a population who were
treated with a her2 targeted drug called
Herceptin and chemotherapy and those are
the blue and the greenish curves then
there was a population that was her to
expressing but it wasn't treated with a
her2 targeted therapy instead it was
only treated with chemotherapy so what
you see on the right-hand side is that
when a patient expresses her to above
our quantitative cutoff and is treated
with Herceptin and chemotherapy that
those patients in the blue curve respond
or performed better
under that therapy then patients in the
greenish curve who are her to positive
her2 expression low and treated with
Herceptin plus chemotherapy so right
here we're seeing the same biology that
we saw in breast cancer that the more
her2 you have the better you respond the
lesser - you have the less well you
respond but what's most striking about
this is the red curve which represents a
her2 treated population a her2
population treated with chemotherapy
alone and what's really important to to
capture here is that this population of
chemotherapy alone and the population of
the green curve which is her2 treated
but Herceptin treated but her too low
was statistically indistinguishable what
this really suggests is it in this
population based on this you know you
know retrospective analysis is it
suggests that there is a population of
patients who have so little her2 that
they're doing no better by being given
Herceptin than if they were just given
chemo alone so now as I said earlier the
key underlying hypothesis of what we do
is that biology matters and it doesn't
matter where you see the biology so this
is a distribution curve that captures
where we see super expression of her to
in any indication now right now you know
clinical testing is limited to breast
cancer and gastric cancer but our
research findings here suggest that
there are many many more places where
her - is overexpressed and may actually
be a therapeutic target and I think from
a clinical research perspective this is
information that needs to be translated
forward so that people understand that
perhaps they should be looking in more
places for high her - because they will
find patients with cancers outside of
where they're used to looking who may be
benefited by these therapies and I think
this is this is a really exciting you
know observation with mass spectrometry
and it really just needs to be pushed so
that more and more people understand it
and I think that you know also many
biology is what matters and was as
Marianne
early on the goal everything that
underlies what we do is understanding
the proteome of cancer so that we can
understand the biology and the final
piece of a her2 story is is here with
bone most technologies that are being
used in the diagnostic lab struggle with
bone metastasis because of the
calcification of the bone and this is a
this is a sample that we received in the
research lab where it was a bone mat and
we were able to analyze it even though
it had been be calcified and this is one
of the exciting pieces of mass
spectrometry as well is that the utility
of the biomarkers when we develop them
it crosses into all different tissue
types so we don't need to be narrowly
focused on you know one indication you
know we can do research we can do you
know protein biomarker research anywhere
and this is a case where the other
technologies ITM fish were not able to
name to analyze this tissue but when we
analyzed it in the research lab we were
able to see that this this tissue
expressed a huge amount of her - and so
this underscores again the need to
understand the biology and the need to
really you know ask the questions what
is driving the tumor and how can we
build protein biomarkers to understand
that so that that's a that's a snapshot
of the targeted therapy space and
there's there's lots of exciting efforts
going on in targeted therapies but we
also have as a goal to understand what
historically has been called you know
unlike smart drugs dumb drugs so
chemotherapy is given to almost every
patient but right now it's not being
used in a biologically targeted way and
I think that what our goal is with
chemotherapy is can we do research on
the potential biomarkers for
chemotherapy drugs and understand
whether or not there are protein
biomarkers which can be informative as
to whether or not the tumor might
respond or not respond
specific chemotherapy and this is
becoming more and more important because
as I'm sure you're all familiar with
this revolution in amino oncology most
chemotherapy drugs have profound impacts
on the immune system they may activate
the immune system or in fact they may
you know suppress the immune system and
the current method of using chemo
without biologically aligning it with
the tumor it has has really profound
impacts on the ability to take the next
step into that immuno column you know
oncology States and then finally in the
drug development areas one of the
exciting spaces that is in development
and research is antibody drug conjugates
and this is an antibody like her to
antibody which happens to be connected
to chemo and the idea of understanding
how chemo can be targeted is really to
understand how whatever biology a
patient's tumor has we can understand it
and then understand what might be good
choices for that tumor so again from the
clinical research side we start all of
our our studies with a retrospective
analysis of clinical trials so this is a
clinical trial it was a gastric cancer
trial and then looked at two different
chemo regimens one which included
docetaxel which is a taxane which blocks
tubulin you know microtubule formation
and another which used the metabolic in
metabolic inhibitor called 500 years old
now the irony is that when they perform
this this clinical trial their
conclusion was that the child failed
there was no difference between these
drugs so what we sought to do is to take
this study and simply ask the question
can the known biomarkers the tug three
which is a tubulin isoform that have
been studied and researched and proposed
to be biomarkers of taxane activity can
we look at this this research study can
we test whether or not the expression of
this this protein tubulin big three has
anything to do with the response of
these patients to taxane
and so we were really excited to see
that indeed
yes and again I compared the
immunohistochemistry data for her to
with the mass spectrometry to show that
mass spectrometry has a much better
range of expression sensitivity and I
think that the same thing is active here
where tubulin beta 3 has been studied
using multiple different technologies
it's only when one does mass
spectrometry that one starts to be able
to see the granularity of expression
that helps us understand what are the
biological expression levels of toulon
beta 3 that might be sufficient to
decrease those attacks all activity so
what we're looking at here is the two
arms of the clinical trial on the left
is the arm which is 125 patients who are
treated with taxane plus platinum and on
the right is 122 patients who are
treated with this 5fu metabolic drug now
our hypothesis is that simulator 3 is
relevant for taxing and you can see on
the left side that when tubulin beta 3
is absent the blue curve those patients
perform better on this therapeutic
regimen than the patients in the red
curve who have tubulin beta 3 so this
supports the idea that yes human beta 3
probably is a resistance marker and when
it's present the patient is likely to
perform worse on this therapy now the
right-hand curve which shows the
patients who weren't given taxing
there's no difference between the
patient's response to this therapeutic
regimen based upon whether there's 2 and
beta 3 present or not
so in this retrospective analysis in a
research setting we would conclude based
on this data that tub 3 is predictive of
response to docetaxel
because it works to separate the
population in a docetaxel treated
population and that has nothing to do
with the outcome in the patients who
aren't being treated with taxa so indeed
if you look at this this population of
patients who have high tubulin beta 3
you can see that the patients who are
treated with bipolar euro cell do far
better than the patients who are treated
with docetaxel so from the research and
development context this is the
that needs to be captured in the
proteomic space to help people
understand the power of using proteomics
and tissue and the power of using
proteomics to understand tumor biology
because you know these targets have been
talked about for years but it's just
never were able to reach the point where
people started to believe the data
because of these other technologies
there was always something missing and I
feel like with the target proteomics
we're starting to push through to where
accurately measuring you know with very
very high specificity we're starting to
see these profound differences in these
populations so I want to talk for a
couple more minutes about the other arm
of that trial so this is a this is a
biological pathway which which is it
results in the synthesis of DNA and RNA
and so there's multiple different
enzymes that are responsible for this
pathway so what we sought to do was to
build asses for all of these targets to
test them all and to see whether or not
the five of you arm was in fact impacted
by the expression of any of these
targets and indeed that it was and so
this is the taxing arm which is on the
last slide where we showed that tubulin
beta 3 was a predictive biomarker and
the 5-fu arm on the right now the 5-fu
arm if we look at this enzyme called
timp we we see that in the presence of
timp in the red curve these patients are
responding better to 5 a few then
patients who don't have Tim and Tim Paz
an enzyme which activates by the few to
become incorporated into DNA and RNA and
cause DNA damage so again taking another
look at this this research study with
our proteomics tools allows us to see
perhaps what can't be seen using other
technologies and when we do this all of
a sudden we see that yes you know tissue
proteomics is a critical tool to
understand the biology of these tumors
and as we go forward I think that the
critical goal is to continue to prove
and Dennis
the assumption that biology matters is
true these are tumors that have
different biology that's impossible to
see without using tissue proteomics but
once one can see the difference in
biology one becomes cognizant of and can
understand how different drugs can
target different pathways and those
tumors and as I said I mean the whole
goal here is you know take these
research studies understand the biology
and then move forward to share this
information so that more and more people
understand the power of tissue
proteomics so with that I will summarize
and I think that the exciting thing for
us is how we've taken a very well
understood mass spec platform that is
one that many many folks are comfortable
with and we utilize standard asset
development tools validation tools
things that everybody should also be
familiar with and we try to apply them
in a different way we try to say look we
know this information is locked up in
the formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue let's find a way to get that
information out let's find a way to
interrogate tumors to better and better
understand the biology and then let's
find a way to test our hypotheses on
these research tissue sets so that we
can understand whether or not these
proteomics tools have a role in defining
the biology of these tumors and with
that I will say thank you very much for
your time thank you for your patience
and we would be happy to answer any
questions that you have about the assay
development the validation or in these
the you know the research oncology data
that I've shared today thank you dr. ham
bro and dr. volson for your informative
presentation and for your important
research through our audience members we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
this webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now we
would appreciate your participation also
in two upcoming polls you will see them
pop up on your screen and we encourage
you to respond by clicking on the answer
that best reflects you
let's begin and take a look at our
audience questions already coming in our
first question is two-part question what
do you think is or are the largest
barriers in generating broader adoption
of MS based proteomics in the clinical
space that's the first question and how
are you making the case for the MS
platform to replace IHC Eliza or other
orthogonal assays well thank you for
that question I think it's an important
question that we all of us in the field
are considering I think one of the main
barriers is probably cost even above you
know trained personnel because we have
many people that are trained and able to
use a mass spec I just think it's not
necessarily as easy it for users in the
clinic however I think cost is a the
largest barrier to entry for the mass
spectrometer into the clinical space but
I think multiplexing our assays give us
a better shot of having a better return
on our investments and bringing the cost
down per test and the clinic thank you
for that question
and thank you dr. volga saying here's
our next question can these same
principles - developing an assay and
ascribing utility to an assay be done
for analysis of blood that's the first
part
another two-part question all right and
are there any challenges or special
considerations that are applied to
analysis of blood using quantitative SRM
assays thank you again
much of the field actually does work in
the blood space primarily I think the
Atomics is pretty unique in that we're
actually working with tissues so yes
these principles can be applied to blood
and and often are in research and as far
as the technicality and considerations
and when you're applying these
methodologies and validating assays in
in blood specimen it's the same you
treat it you know the interference that
you might see in
any of your mass effect signal would be
treated the same as if there were blood
or from a tissue it's still the same
technical validation process that you
would run through Thanks
these are fun questions and and we have
some great questions coming in from our
audience members today our next question
you mentioned global proteomics on an
intro slide but don't discuss it in the
rest of the slides how have you
incorporated global proteomics into your
approach oh thanks yeah we did we have
started to build a global proteomics
discovery department here and a lot of
what our assays have built on
historically were basically targeted
proteomics and so we used a lot of the
literature based and genomic based
knowledge that we already had in health
and built assays around that and now
we're starting to let global proteomics
guide our next set of assays that we're
developing thank you have you gotten any
examples from any type of brain tumor
om3 oh yeah we work with all types of
specimen in our research and in our
clinical laboratory and so yes we have
okay
thank you our next question mm-hmm
what advice do you have for unknown
biomarker ID using mass spectometry so
can you repeat that again please
sure I mean what advice do you have for
unknown biomarker ID using mass
spectometry so I guess there's a lot of
ways you can go about this question you
can if it's unknown really it's in the
discovery phase you're looking at your
differential of signals and you can
still carry through this process even
without an eye
identification if you want to just go
based on the mass spec signal and
generate an assay on it but I do think
that if you really want to have be an
essay in the clinic you have to truly
characterize that target if I'm answer
no you're rushing like I don't think
that person can type it in again or
follow up please thanks great and again
thank you audience members for your
incoming questions
our next question how do I find the
marker for other types of cancer is
there a list or a resource of known type
types of markers for all cancer types oh
I love this question thank you actually
here at name tommix I like to think are
we concern ourselves indication agnostic
so as far as cancers are concerned we
run our entire platform and our entire
pipeline of assays on any cancer
regardless of the type because we think
that the biology is characterizing the
cancer or not this is where the cancer
itself and so any given target can
express in any given type of cancer
Thanks hmm thank you dr. Vogel thing we
have time for one more question and I
want to make sure I give you some time
to provide some last words which mass
spectometry did you use for your work
and as I mentioned before a lot of our
you know the history and our development
of all our assay so far was built on
triple quad mass spectrometers it's only
now recently that we're using our wheat
based instruments for discovery efforts
but right now routinely when we're
quantitating all of our targets we're
still doing them on the triple
quadrupole instruments great thank you
so much and if you like and I just want
to remind audience members that any
other questions coming in will be
responded via email from our presenters
did you want to provide any last closing
remarks to our audience dr. Golding well
I want to thank everyone for
participating
and listening to today's webinar it was
a really fun experience for me and I
hope I was able to help listeners and
please if you do have any questions Todd
and I would be happy to follow up
through email thanks and thank you very
much and thank you dr. Hembrough as well
- I'd also like to take the opportunity
to thank lab roots and thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational web past possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through late 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know that this webcast will
be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon goodbye